hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round 5 of this
year's video World Cup it is a former uh
participant of the video candidates
tournament along how here facing ukesh
who is just in incredible lately he
entered the top 10 and now he enters
number nine number eight and he he wants
to go all the way but it is the you know
Youth and
um uh as usual youth versus experience
and uh sometimes it goes in favor of
youth youth sometimes it goes in favor
of experience uh let's see what happened
in this one as it's uh it's a pretty
exciting game the ninja Indian defense
of course always
um enjoyable to watch uh let's see what
they come up with so long how has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 uh C4 E6 Knight to C3
and of course the bishop to B4 the names
of Indian defense is on the board we
have Queen to C2 the classical variation
and pawn to D5 now we have captors on
the five captures and now Bishop to G5
uh we have H6 and now Bishop to H4 we
have castles and upon the E3 Pawn to C5
and now D captures and C5 and now Bishop
to E6 so all been played before nothing
new here Knight to F3 and now Knight
beta D7 are preparing to capture back on
C5 and here uh the you could continue
with something like A3 and actually try
to defend your C3 Pawn this is possible
but you give black uh a lot of um
counter-attacking possibilities for
example uh Bishop captures Queen
captures okay you can defend the pawn
but then come to G5 Bishop to G3 and
let's say Knights the E4 you attack the
queen and also there's a double attack
on the C5 Pawn so you can't really
defend that pawn so instead C6 is the
main move here this is what the vancou
goes for uh we have B counters and C6
and now Bishop to E2 and here there is a
game where C5 was played by Gucci for
Queen to A5 and it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game it's
okay on count Castle so of course you
don't want this pin to remain there
forever the bishop captures on C3 and
now B captures and C3 now about the the
trade Queens this would make gookish um
uh well game a bit easier there won't be
so much in the position and then he
would just wait for his chances tomorrow
with the white pieces so here of course
one cow once done I play a little bit
more we have Knights the E4 uh and uh
Rook F to C1 you have to defend your C3
Pawn we have Pawn to C5 now Google
controlling a lot of very important
squares here and pawn to see for trying
to undermine the Knight on e4 we have
Rook 8 to B8 and now Knight the E1 uh
the idea being probably capturing on D5
and then after Bishop captures uh
kicking away the knight from E4 with F3
this would kick away the Knight and also
minimize the the power of the bishop on
this very new D4 Square so that's the
idea we have Queen to A3 and now C
captures on D5 Bishop characters and
queen to D3 here uh one cow offers the
queen trade and goukash accepts Queen
characters and D3 Bishop characters and
pawn to G5 now now before moving the
bishop he eliminates the Knight Bishop
captures on e4 Bishop captures and
Bishop to G3 comes with Tempo The Rook
is hanging so Rook to B7 and pawn to F3
now with Bishop back to G6 and now Rook
to D1 uh we have rooked the C8 now
preparing to start pushing the the fast
C Pawn because the material is equal
it's even a bishop and uh and Knight
versus the bishop and Knight of course
both players having a rook pair but it's
Bishops of opposite color so the main
thing you realize in the position is
that it is only gookish that has a past
Pawn so Pawn to E4 and bookish starts
pushing his Pawn with Pawn to C4 Knights
a C2 and of course Pawn to C3 he already
has a rule behind the pass Pawn so that
works well for him and now comes Rook to
D6 you could also continue with Knight
to E3 it would control a lot of squares
from from here and then decide where to
go from there but he goes for Rook to D6
first and this uh uh fights against
Google's plan of going Pawn to F5
because he really wants to play Pawn to
F5 to three of the bishop once E4 was
played this bishop is pretty much out of
the game so he has to prepare it Knight
to a fate this defends the bishop and
now he will uh play sorry about that uh
and that pawn to F5 so Rook the C1
putting the Rook behind or in this case
in front of the pass pawn and now Pawn
to F5 we have rooked the D4 and now
Knight the E6 Chase is away the Rook
Rook the B4 offering a rook trade and
now Rook to D7 avoiding the trade for
now but you want to go all the way to
the to the second rank uh so Knight to
the E3 and now we have F captures and he
4f captures and Rook to D3 attacking the
Knight here on E3 and here Bishop TF2
was played and this is where one house
problems really start what you have to
do here is uh just cut your losses with
Rook to C4 and then uh okay now you are
threatening to capture the rook and see
it if the Rook moves you can also just
capture on C3 and defend your knight
this way so a trade here will happen
captures captures you give up the E4
pawn and then you go for something like
95 you attack The Rook after The Rook
moves you'll play Rook captures on C3
and you have to give up the G2 and the
A2 and A1 Pawn and after Rook captures
on G2 checking if one will capture some
A2 uh okay you're down two pawns but
maybe you can still save this somehow so
this is the absolute best way to play
unfortunately for one call however
Bishop to FD was played and now look at
this Knight to F4 uh we have rooked the
C2 and now Rook the D2 offering a trade
of Works which of course you cannot
accept H3 now Knights to D3 now putting
pressure on the bishop here as well and
again only one way to play this uh Rook
to A4 is the only way to continue if
Rook to A4 the idea was Knight captures
and F2 and after Rook captures on D2 now
you snatch another Pawn with Knight
captures on H3 and after G captures you
capture the rook and D2 and now you go
behind the pass Pawn of course The Rook
the C3 goes after the Knight you're
gonna defend the Knight sorry about that
uh you're gonna defend the Knight with
King F2 and now Bishop captures on e4 is
the final trick that grabs another Pawn
you cannot capture because uh uh if Rook
captures then root captures and E3
removes the defender of the D1 square
and you're just gonna Queen on the next
move or you go Rook D4 and then Rook
captures on H3 again you have too much
material so you can play that after
Bishop captures and E4 you basically
have to go after the D2 pawn and that's
it the the game continues the black is
up Pawn with a very nice position
whether black and wind is that is up to
the player with the black pieces but
after Knight to D3 uh of course both of
them were very low on time bang how much
much lower and time he had like a minute
on the clock Google had around four
minutes on the clock and he played Rook
captures on D2 but now the game is
completely winning for gokish and okay
his next move is forcing C captures on
D2 but now there there is no more move
for y so that's the problem so uh he did
he didn't even pose a problem for us to
use as a pause the video Moment The Rook
captures and D2 is just is just
completely uh lost position and there's
nothing you can do about it the problem
is how do you fight against Rook to see
one check if you play Rook to B1 and
it'll just work the C1 with check
there's nothing you can play here so
Rook the D4 was played but now again
Rook the C1 with check and now of course
if you block with the Knight then the
Knight no longer controls the queening
square so here King the H2 was played
but now the bishop and F2 hangs Knight
captures on F2 was played and he was in
this position unmoved 38 uh that wankhao
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so it was a bad
position in time trouble before even
reaching time control the game ended on
move 38 you need two more moves to reach
time control to be granted additional
time and there just wasn't anything long
Hao could do Lucas outplayed him little
by little he just used this a very very
cool line of the uh of the names of
Indian defense this queen to A5 being
the new move and okay you use the pretty
standard stuff the pressure on C3 then
you use the pressure on e4 uh then you
push C5 then you bring the Rooks in so
very nicely done by him and one cow
couldn't take on all of this pressure so
it will be up to him to bounce back
tomorrow with the white pieces uh with
the black pieces tomorrow gookish will
be having the white pieces which is also
not a good news for one call so here
okay you resign because you're down too
much material you could play some like
Rook captures on D2 but now even Rook
the H1 check King G3 Knight captures any
four with check you're down a full piece
uh and uh there's just no playing being
down a full piece without any at least
positional compensation or or something
yeah very nicely done uh by uh by Gucci
here are the the new new live ratings
I'm sure you guys are interested in this
so okay magnet is still in number one
with 2837 uh followed by Fabiano Corona
in second Hikaru in third dinglier and
still in 40 although not playing uh 50
yanny Paul machine six and gulkish now
jumps to number seven overtakes uh
Wesley Solutions and Anish giri so
absolutely incredible but now it's gonna
take a lot of grinding to reach the the
heights of of uh
and of course much much later Magnus
Carlsen and here for those of you who
are interested in all of the results of
round five these are the results so you
know Skip it if you don't want your day
spoiled uh these are the results Magnus
Carlsen defeated Vaseline when chukwang
Khao lost to Google as you've just seen
uh ninjat abasov has defeated Salim
Salim they were the last two playing uh
it was a drone position but Sal and
Saleh made a terrible blunder and I was
so just took advantage of it brilliantly
with it drew against Nepal carwana Drew
Against The Duda Dominguez defeated Alex
is
Drew his game against Terence Becker so
we'll see what happens in round two if I
manage I'm gonna try and show at least
one more game if you have a favorite as
usual do use hashtag suggestion uh and
yeah that's pretty much it I hope you
guys enjoyed it again big
congratulations to go cash for crushing
absolutely everyone with such ease even
here with the black pieces it's just
amazing how he he does it we'll see if
he can continue this all the way and
maybe even qualify for the candidates
tournament actually I once again really
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank you young Emily
hochsteinberg and a Serena mascar shop
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this uh brilliant event
until it finishes uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day